i was reminded recently of this
documentary i watched called hitman
heart which is a great documentary
hitman heart it's about pro wrestling
brett the hitman heart yeah
that's right that's right and he's the
good guy he was the good guy in pro
wrestling and so and he was very very
famous he was the most famous canadian
of his time as it turned out and
he had this role thrust upon him he was
the good guy
right yeah and watching the documentary
i realized that
people watched pro wrestling because it
was a battle in a coliseum between the
forces of good and the forces of evil
and i didn't understand that i didn't
know it was a drama for people who
didn't want to go to movies like it was
one
level of fiction below movies i'm not
being smart about this
like i'm not i'm not being cynical about
this yeah yeah i didn't realize that it
was a mythological drama
yeah and hitman heart got cast as you
know this
the hero the the savior essentially yeah
and that was very weighty for him
because that's what people expected from
him
but in any case there was a
sophisticated psychological drama that
was being played out in the wrestling or
in the wrestling ring and it was good
against evil and that fantasy that you
have of protecting the people you love
against malevolent and malicious
intruders is
the fantasy of good against evil it's
just concretized
yeah and so you abs you see like in our
religious doctrines in
at the core of religious doctrine much
religious doctrine is the idea that the
entire world is a stage
for the battle between good and evil and
that's right
right we know it's right you know that's
happening in your own conscience because
you torture yourself when you do things
that you shouldn't do
yeah you want to see yourself on the
side of the good
you want to be on the side of the good
insofar as you're motivated by
by the proper and appropriate intentions
yeah yeah
and you'll so you'll see that in a
fantasy and it is part of friendship to
defend and guard but
you want to make that sophisticated
enough so you don't get the bad guy
wrong because sometimes the bad guy
you're saying is not
a person so well sometimes the bad guy
is you
sometimes like it's better and this is
something i tried to stress in my
writings is
the the forces of good and evil are
inside yeah
they're best conceptualized
psychologically it's this it's the most
appropriate way to conceptualize them
get yourself under control right yeah
quell the devil in your own soul
yeah it's the best thing you can do for
your friends because otherwise it
risks getting acted out at a much more
concrete level and then it becomes
dangerous
you know it's the the protesters who are
shaking their fists all the time they've
identified evil outside
yes and that's what they're fighting and
you know you can understand that
motivation
yeah but the problem for me is like what
makes you so sure that the evil is where
you think it is
it's not it's so convenient for you that
it's outside
i don't think it's outside i don't want
to misquote you but uh
you said something about um there is no
uh there's a i don't know there's a
there's no limit to what human beings
will do
in the pursuit of good there's no limit
to the evil human beings will do in the
pursuit of good
something like that well the idea of
utopia you imagine that sort of
revolutionary utopia yeah how many
utopia that the revolution is going to
bring it's like yeah well it's so
good yeah that anything i do to bring it
about is
justifiable yes yes yes jesus you've
just been handed a blank moral card you
can get away with bloody murder because
after all you know you can't make an
omelet without breaking a few eggs
right right so away we go breaking eggs
it's like well
it's better we better be one hell of an
omelet yeah
yeah even then it's not clear it's
justifiable
look see in sophisticated literature you
know in unsophisticated literature
there's evil people and there's
good people and they have a battle right
in sophisticated literature the good and
evil are within the characters
that that's the the thing about um to
make it very unsophisticated but
marvel i think what they get so well
about their villains
is that they make their is they make
their their goal
somewhat relatable you know like there's
this thanos character who's like i want
to remove
half of life in the universe and
everybody's like oh my god you're a
piece of [ __ ] that's horrible
and then he's like no i saw what
happened on my planet and there was no
more resources and the people just
killed each other and was absolutely
horrible so if i just remove half of
life and rich people poor people
everybody gets taken out in the same way
then there'll be plenty of food there'll
be plenty of resources for everybody and
everybody will live happily ever after
and all of a sudden you're like okay
he's a psychopath
but he has good intentions with his
psychopathy
you know so now you relate to this
[ __ ] villain in a weird way
and i guess what i'm saying is yes that
is that is the the more sophisticated
storytelling that i really like
i want to relate to the villain i want
to look at the joker
yes of course because you want to
grapple with those sorts of forces
inside yourself too and you want to see
where i'm not
here what's that i'm not a hero i
always will relate to the villain more
because i'm not captain [ __ ] america
you know i i'm battling i imagine we
probably relate to the villain if it's a
sophisticated villain
way more than the hero because the hero
isn't really dynamic he's not really
battling a lot
in a lot of these like superhero movies
like superman what the [ __ ] does he have
to deal with
the fact that he's faking that it's a
big problem with superman right i mean
he got to the point where because he
could do everything there was nothing to
do
yeah there's no story boring give me a
regular guy that's going through some
[ __ ]
yeah well that is what marvel did when
they burst onto the scene in the early
60s right they made their they also made
the heroes more complex and
and and and more multi-dimensional in
their motivations
you